So a lot of fun
went down at Kaer Morhen,
but it built up
to what we could call
the Monster Mash at the end,
Witchers vs basilisks
vs Voleth Ciri.
Talk us through shooting
that epic fight together.
How were the basilisks on set?
Were they just super divas?
Oh, I loved it.
I loved it because you're
doing something so epic,
and you know
that it's gonna look epic.
But essentially, you've got,
like, stuntmen in spandex
operating puppet heads,
foam puppet heads,
all in bright green.
So I sometimes would giggle,
because I would catch myself
trying to be
all stoic and serious,
and then,
there's a guy in green spandex
in front of me.
Waving his head.
But then you know, like,
when I saw it in ADR
and I was like,
"Woo! Okay, great."
But it was brilliant.
And, you know, long days,
but we were able to--
I think everybody was just
so hyped to be doing it.
It was lovely.
Yasen, had you ever done
that kind of fighting before?
-Not like that.
-Okay.
Not like that.
I remember I had a small kip
before we went to do
one of them.
The first time, actually,
that they were on set, right?
-Yeah.
-And I was...I woke up,
and I was still in a daze,
and I was, like,
checks and everything.
I walked onto set,
and like you said,
I just saw two, like,
green condoms just...
...just staring me in the face,
and I was still, like,
trying to just kinda
wake up a little bit.
I thought, "What on earth
is going on here
with these big heads?"
And they were like,
"We're gonna fight that."
And I was like, "All right."
And then I said to Lambert,
"What the hell is that?"
He was like...
I just went,
"They're basilisks, Coen."
Basilisks.
I was like, "Okay."
Kim, you had so many
wonderful dramatic moments
during those fight sequences.
How do you ground yourself
in the reality of your character
when all these... I mean,
they are kinda silly things
are happening on set,
but you really have
to find your reality,
and these kind of
ridiculous things
that the audience
will never see,
but that's what you're
experiencing as a person.
How do you ground yourself?
I love the illusion world.
I love to visualize everything,
and they're so good today
that you can see everything
on iPads, what's going on.
But, I mean,
you are in a room that,
as Lauren said,
is built one to one,
so you really get the illusion
how big these monsters are.
Also knowing,
Lauren told me,
"We need your emotional stuff.
Come on,"
and you just gave me
more and more to work with,
it was, like, scary!
The last fight is scary,
it's so scary for me,
it's like, why?
Why didn't I see that come?
Well, it really grounds
the whole sequence.
I mean, it's not only
spectacular visual-wise
but also emotionally.
There's so many wonderful
culminations of the season.
And we really wanted that.
We really wanted
to put that in
as a statement,
because it's not normal
you see so much feeling
in such a big fight,
you know,
because it has to go fast.
I remember when you put it
together, and saying,
"These characters have to show
the emotional stuff into it,"
so it's like a break.
It's like in the fight you stop time to go into our emotional stuff,
and that was incredible,
as an actor,
to have the opportunity to
then you couldn't let it go,
you had to follow it.
It's like you're fighting
and it's going so fast,
and you really don't know
what's going on,
and then it stops,
time stops!
And you have all your time.
-It's so wonderful.
-It's so crazy good!
Was there a specific challenge,
Lauren,
in crafting that finale that
you wanna show the audience?
I mean, I can't imagine
it was easy in any way,
but what was
the biggest challenge?
Um, there were so,
so many challenges.
I mean, COVID,
let's start with that.
But no, I mean, I think
Kim kind of landed on it,
which is,
I think that so often,
epic battles lose
their emotionality,
and yet, what we learned,
honestly,
through our fight sequences
in Season 1,
is that without changing
if a battle doesn't
change a character,
if a fight doesn't
then it's not worth doing.
And Kim is absolutely right.
So much of a battle
is about frenetic pace,
is about making sure
that it looks cool,
and yet, constantly,
we'd be stopping on set
to say, "No.
We need to land on Vesemir
in this moment.
We need to land
on Lambert and Coen
as they're realizing
that these monsters
are coming into their home,
and that shouldn't be able
to happen."
So it really was
about timing it all out
and asking
these brilliant actors
to trust what felt like
a weird rhythm on the day,
that we would be able
to build it,
and I think, I mean, honestly,
I think it's the biggest thing
we've ever done
and one of my favorites.
Like what you see?
Be sure to check out
the full episode
of The Witcher: Unlocked,
the official Netflix Geeked
aftershow.